bakugo squirk is Awakening and all for
one is on the run the truth about the
second one for all user and his
connection to bakugo is finally being
revealed and both Deku and bakugo are
about to awaken the full potential of
their quirks in the final battle in the
entire series the grand finale of mha is
finally here so let's get into it you
guys know all this works if you enjoy my
M videos and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment
right now it only takes you a second but
it helps me out a lot with that YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help this
channel attain Quirk Singularity by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
big favor and subscribe right now we are
so close finally this video will of
course contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous chapter
confirmed that all might's fate had been
changed and that even though he was
supposed to die in this battle against
young all for one he managed to survive
thanks to the collective efforts of his
students and everyone throughout the
world who was rooting for him and so
night ey's dark prophecy about all
might's tragic death is no longer
relevant at this point in the story we
also learned that bakugo's Quirk acted
on its own in order to revive him edshot
managed to physically repair bakugo's
organs but they were not working and his
heart was not beating then a beat of
sweat that bakugo had produced before he
died came through his bloodstream and
exploded which is what jumpstarted his
heart and other organs this means that
bakuga Quirk has evolved to a point that
it could act on its own in order to help
its user which is a lot like how
oneforall acted on its own to protect
Deku from shinso's mind control this
raised the question is bakugo sork
evolving and Awakening or is it maybe
fusing with one for all since bakugo did
temporarily get to use one for all back
during the second mha movie the latest
chapter starts off with some quick
updates on what's happening on all the
major battlefields as we prepared to
witness the final battle on the final
Battlefield as we know Shi and Kota were
were triumphant in the battle for the
hospital they are both okay and now all
the wounded are being taken care of well
I guess they weren't completely
triumphant because kurogiri was able to
escape but they did manage to subdue all
the villains including the gigantify
spinner the nomu on okuto island has
been defeated and gang orca's wounds are
being cared for by Sirius how was the
noo defeated by gang Orca offscreen
somehow we don't know ayama and tou are
currently working hard to rescue
everyone from Kun has deadly piranha
plants now that he's been successfully
defeated and the ketsubutsu Gang have
taken skeptic into custody the
evacuation of civilians is being
completed as we speak and the villains
in jaku have all been neutralized some
villains are still actively resisting
like one named gley who is fighting
against ryuku ojiro and a bunch of other
Heroes but overall things are clearly
wrapping up everywhere but the main
Battlefield the villains are losing the
heroes are winning and she shigaraki and
aleran are pretty much the last
significant players on the villain side
who are still standing considering how
this all started and what a bad position
the hero Society was in at the beginning
of the final Arc we have to give it to
the heroes because they've really done
well overall that said there are still
some unresolved plot points including
what happened to kuroi aawa and present
Mike they are all still missing and
their whereabouts are currently unknown
we also see a glimpse of sniper wfu l
aant lying down on the roof with her
rifle in hand she is injured but she is
alive and she remembers what rocklock
said the entire plan depends on isuku
midoria and they are all counting on him
lady Nagant included but is it really
all about Deku I think bakugo would have
a thing or two to say about that
speaking of bakugo back on the main
Battlefield everyone is shocked to see
the extent of bakugo's speed and the
sheer power of His explosions including
all might himself snake shot explains
that the incredible speed that bakugo
unlocked right before dying shocked
everyone including even shigaraki and
bakugo himself so bakugo still has to
adjust to this new power he is learning
new things about his quirk in real time
and he has to keep using his quirk in
order to perfect his new powers for his
part all for one is angry that bakugo is
challenging him bakugo's massive
explosion blew Al foran right into a
building and that means that the villain
is sustaining even more damage all for
one wants to kill bakugo because he
can't let some random guy damage him
further and speed up his rewinding
meanwhile shikaki is fine with bakugo's
new power up because he believes that he
can just break bakugo again and he
intends to do exactly that however our
boy deu is a bit concerned although he
has been effectively using his multiple
quirks to fight shigaraki he still
hasn't been able to overcome the fact
that shigaraki has his awakened Decay
Quirk combined with a super human body
and super regeneration together these
powers are absolutely devastating and
shigaraki has been using them to his
Advantage very effectively deu knows
that he is only able to use gearshift
one more time and he also knows that
after his final time he will face a
devastating blowback he will pay dearly
for ignoring the second user's advice
and overusing gearshift nevertheless deu
believes that the time to use his final
gear shift is right now he has to
surpass his limits against shigaraki and
go plus Ultra just like bakugo intends
to do the same against all for one but
to bakugo's disappointment all for one
has finally realized that he doesn't
have any more time to waste instead of
spending more time fighting bakugo he
flies off as fast as he can towards
shigaraki he needs to secure his new
vessel right away because he could be
rewound out of existence at any moment
he will deal with bakugo and his Quirk
later and he is confident that he can
kill bakugo and overcome his Quirk but
first things first he has to reach
shigaraki right now and yet we all know
bakugo and we know he's not about to
back down now he does not want to be a
side character in fact bakugo is
beginning to realize why his Quirk is
evolving and why he is now able to move
so quickly and create more powerful
explosions the key to everything is pain
when he redirects the sweat that should
be going into his palms throughout the
the rest of his body bakuga begins to
feel an absolutely brutal amount of pain
but if he can determine where exactly on
his body he has experiencing the most
pain he can use that pain to create much
more powerful explosions he can use the
pain to make his Quirk stronger bakugo
uses his Quirk to chase all for one
through the air and he is able to
actually successfully keep up with all
for one speed the villain is clearly
shocked by this and he is beginning to
get worried about this crazy explosive
Maniac even though though bakugo is
bouncing off the ground and feeling a
ton of pain he is laughing and loving
every moment of this even he can't
believe the extent of his speed bakugo
thinks back to all the times he wondered
if Deku had gotten too strong for him
and if he would ever be able to catch up
to his rival again but now with this new
PowerUp Baku believes that he will not
only be able to catch up to Deku but
even surpass him okay take it easy there
bakugo I know it's hard for our boy Lord
explosion murder to accept this but Deku
is the protagonist of this story he's
the one with seven different quirks and
he's the one that's going to play the
main role in defeating shigaraki in the
end that's just how mha works so no I
don't think bakugo will successfully
surpass Deku but I'm glad to see that
bakugo has gotten much stronger and that
he can now make a real difference in the
battle even bakugo's parents are
watching the fight unfold on one of the
screens in the civilian evacuation
Center bakugo's dad doesn't even want to
look at the screen because he doesn't
want to see something bad happen to his
son but bakugo's hot mom says says that
they have to watch bakugo's battle he
must be smiling as always smiling and
fighting Against All Odds and they have
to be there for him and support him no
matter how hard it might be for them
back to all for one he cannot understand
why bakugo makes him so mad if anything
it seems like bakugo makes him even
angrier than all might made him when he
was trying to provoke him and as the
villain tries to figure out what about
bakugo makes him so mad he realizes that
it's because bakugo looks so much like
the second one for all user all for one
remembers the time when he had finally
caught up to the second user all those
years ago and in that moment the second
user told him that if he's looking for
his brother yoichi he is already gone
yoichi is dead and all for one was the
one who killed him this seems to upset
all for one as if he didn't realize that
his brother was dead it's interesting
that the second user claims that all for
one killed his brother and yet all for
one didn't seem to realize that his
brother was dead but I wonder if maybe y
was killed indirectly as a result of all
for one's actions say what you will
about all for one but he did care about
his brother he tried to improve his
brother squirk he tried to keep his
brother close to him rather than harming
him and he was hoping that eventually
yoichi would see where all for one was
coming from but of course that never
happened because yichi was rescued from
his captivity and he joined the
resistance against all for one all for
one is furious and he blames the second
user Kudo for everything if Kudo hadn't
broken yichi out of all for one's
captivity and made him a part of the
resistance none of this would have
happened yoichi would still be alive all
for one would still have control over
both his brother and his brother's Quirk
and the resistance to all for one's
tyranny would be much weaker than It
ultimately became so that is why all for
one hates the second user Kudo and why
he yells out kudo's name angrily but
instead of Kudo our boy bakugo responds
he says are you senile I am the one and
only kachan bakugo and that is how this
chapter ends bro I cannot believe that
the great explosion murder God Dynamite
would refer to himself as kachan cringe
okay I'm kidding but his hero name is
definitely way more badass than freaking
kachan okay I'm sorry Deku it's just the
way it is it was kind of crazy to see
all foran actually getting worried about
fighting bakugo and then choosing to
flee from him rather than fight him head
on that's got to tell you how powerful
bakugo is becoming and how much of a
threat he now poses to even the most
powerful villains bakugo squirk is
clearly in the process of Awakening and
I'm so curious to find out what his
absolute full power will look like not
only is he now faster and able to
produce way stronger explosions but his
Quirk seems to be able to act on its own
in critical moments and that could be
absolutely huge in this final battle oh
and deu is apparently about to use his
final gear shift and then he is going to
experience a massive blowback what do
you guys think this will mean mean for
the final fight like will Deku be taken
out of commission by the blowback at
least for a while and then other Heroes
will need to fight shigaraki until Deku
recovers or do you think that Deku will
just surpass his limits again maybe his
Quirk will evolve even further like Baku
goes and the two of them will both
attain their ultimate final powerups at
the same time that would be pretty
freaking amazing to see I am still
wondering whether there will be some
sort of connection between awakened
explosion and awakened one for all like
if they are going to build off of each
other other or maybe even share each
other's powers in the final battle what
do you guys think what will be the final
evolution of bakugo squirk and deu
squirk will all for one actually lose to
bakugo oneon-one is there any connection
between bakugo and the second user other
than the fact that they just look
similar will deu be taken out of
commission by the blowback or will he
just keep pushing through finally what
do you think will ultimately happen to
Kuro GID isawa and present Mike will
they still play some role in the story
or is the story pretty much over for
them definitely let me know what you
think down in the comments below if
you're looking for another mha video to
watch right now you can always check out
my video about the last chapter link on
screen and in the description if you
enjoy my MJ content and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
right now and if you want to help this
channel attain Quirk Singularity by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
big favor and subscribe right now we are
very close